>> Greg: AS THE MEDIA AND
DEMOCRATS.
HEALING, THEIR LOUDEST VOICES
ARE PLANNING SOMETHING ELSE.
THEY CALL IT ACCOUNTABILITY BUT
IT’S ACTUALLY RETRIBUTION.
TWO WEEKS AGO I DESCRIBED HOW
ROBERT RICE GOT THE BALL ROLLING
SUGGESTING THAT THE LEFT SHAME
ANYONE CAME TO DETROIT.
THE BEARDED BOZO EXCUSE THE
SENATOR UNDER BELLY.
THEN THERE IS HARRY, FORMER A
OBAMA SPOKESMAN WHO TOUTED THE
PROJECT WHICH VOWS TO KEEP
ANYONE TRUMP EMPLOYED FROM
GETTING WORK.
THEIR MOTTO, REMEMBER WHAT THEY
DID.
OTHERS HAVE SINCE JOINED THE
VENGEFUL MOB.
CHRIS HAYES.
THE "PHILLY INQUIRER," THE
NATION, THE ALWAYS DELIGHTFUL
AOC.
WHO CAN FORGET THIS DERANGED
NUGGET?
>> SHUNNING, SHAMING THESE
PEOPLE IS A STATEMENT OF MORAL
INDIGNATION THAT THESE PEOPLE
ARE NOT FIT FOR POLITE SOCIETY.
IT’S NOT ONLY THAT TRUMP HAS TO
LOSE BUT ALL HIS ENABLERS HAVE
TO LOSE.
THEY HAVE TO -- WE HAVE TO
COLLECTIVELY IN ESSENCE BURNED
DOWN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WE HAVE TO LEVEL THEM BECAUSE IF
THERE ARE SURVIVORS, IF THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO WEATHER THE
STORM, THEY WILL DO IT AGAIN.
>> Greg: SHE IS GROSS.
NO WONDER TRUMP VOTERS WERE SHY
AROUND THE MEDIA.
AND THE NOSY POLLSTERS.
IT’S NEVER BEEN ABOUT COMPROMISE
UNLESS IT’S REPLACING
COMPROMISE.
I WISH THEY WOULD WEAR BROWN
SHIRTS AND WE WOULD RECOGNIZE
THEM.
THIS AIN’T NEW.
IT BEGAN YEARS AGO BEFORE THIS
ELECTION.
SHUTTING DOWN SPEAKERS, BANNING
PEOPLE FROM MEDIA PLATFORMS,
CANCEL CULTURE, THE DELUSIONAL
WOKE-ISM THAT ENERGIZES THE MOB
AND THE STREETS IN POLITICS AND
MEDIA.
PEOPLE LOSING JOBS AND
BUSINESSES, CRIMINALS BURNING
BUILDINGS.
WHY NOT?
A WITCH HUNT.
IT FITS.
IMAGINE THE REVERSE AFTER A
TRUMP WIN.
HIS FANS VOWING TO CREATE --
YOU CAN’T IMAGINE IT BECAUSE WE
ARE NORMAL.
WE SEE PEOPLE BEFORE WE SEE
POWER AND THIS IS ALL ABOUT
POWER.
FOR US, POWER IS JUST A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE BUT FOR THE
LEFT, ONCE THEY GET A WHIFF, THE
FREE BASE THE WHOLE STASH.
THEN IN THEIR FEVERISH HIGH,
THEY GET THE MUNCHIES.
SORRY.
YOU ARE THE MEAL.
JESSE, IF I’M NOT ON A LIST OR
IF YOU’RE NOT ON THE LIST, IF
YOU AND I ARE ON A LIST, I
BETTER BE ABOVE YOU ON THE LIST.
>> Jesse: YOU DESERVE TO BE
ABOVE ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK WOULD GET
RID OF THE CYCLE OF REVENGE
POLITICS?
ALCOHOL.
IT WASN’T TOO LONG AGO WHERE
CONGRESSMAN USED TO GO OUT AND
THEY WOULD GO OUT DRINKING AND
DOING GOD KNOWS WHAT UNTIL THE
SUN COMES UP.
THEY GOT TO KNOW EACH OTHER AND
THEY BONDED AND THAT WAS WHEN
DEMOCRATS USED TO THINK
REPUBLICANS WERE AN EVIL.
THEY WERE GREEDY.
LET’S RETURN TO YOU THINKING
THAT WE ARE GREEDY.
I THINK AOC IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WOMAN
SHOULD GO TO THE HAY ADAMS AFTER
LEAVING CAPITOL HILL.
MAYBE POMPEO SHOULD COME OVER
AND THEY SHOULD NOT BACK DRINKS.
>> Dana: IT DOES HELP.
>> Jesse: THEY WOULD GET TO
KNOW EACH OTHER.
THEY WERE ACTUAL PEOPLE.
ONCE -- WHEN JUAN AND I WENT OUT
UNTIL 4:00 A.M. TO THE BLACK
EYESEYED PEAS CONCERT.
>> Jesse: I AM MORE DISGUSTED
THAT HE WENT TO A BLACK-EYED
PEAS CONCERT.
JUAN, ON ONE SIDE YOU HAVE YOUR
LEADER SAYING THAT IT’S TIME FOR
HEALING AND THEN YOU HAVE AN
UNDERCURRENT SAYING NOT SO FAST.
>> Juan: WAIT A SEC.
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
BEFORE POWER.
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT FIRES
THE DEFENSE SECRETARY.
HE GOES AFTER --
THAT’S NOT CANCELING.
>> Juan: HE GOES AFTER THE
PERSON WHO DOES OUR NATIONAL
CLIMATE CHANGE ASSESSMENT.
GETS RID OF THEM.
SO I GUESS IT’S ABOUT POWER,
WOULDN’T YOU SAY?
>> Greg: NOT MAKING ANY SENSE.
>> Juan: HE SHOULD BE FIGHTING
THE VIRUS.
HE SHOULD BE DOING THINGS TO
HELP AMERICA AND HE’S INVOLVED
WITH PEOPLE AND YOU SAY NO,
DEMOCRATS PUT POWER BEFORE -- I
SEE POWER PLAYS ALL THE TIME.
>> Greg: THAT’S MY POINT.
>> Juan: PEOPLE HERE ON THIS
SHOW COME OWN WE MAKE MISTAKES,
PEOPLE CALL US ON IT.
WHEN WE TELL LIES, PEOPLE CALL
US ON IT.
WHY DO YOU SAY IT’S TERRIBLE
THAT PEOPLE WANT TO SAY THAT
PEOPLE INVOLVED WITH ENABLING
TRUMP SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
IT SEEMS THERE SHOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR BAD BEHAVIOR.
>> Greg: THERE SHOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR ANYBODY THAT
SUPPORTS TRUMP.
>> Juan: WHAT KIND OF
CONSEQUENCES.
IF A CORPORATION, IF I’M RUNNING
A CORPORATION AND I SEE YOU KNOW
WHAT I THINK THIS PERSON DID
SOMETHING THE DAMAGES ARE
DEMOCRACY, OUR SENSE OF PURPOSE
AS --
I LOVE AMERICA.
>> Jesse: SO YOU WOULDN’T HIRE
ANYONE WHO WORKED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Juan: DEPENDS ON WHO IT IS.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE GONE TO THE
DEVIL, JUAN.
WHAT YOU SAID IS PEOPLE CAN BE
PUNISHED FOR HAVING A DIFFERENT
OPINION.
>> Juan: I DID NOT SAY THAT.
I LIVE HERE WITH THE DIFFERENT
OPINION.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> Katie: THE HAY ADAMS IS FAR
TOO CLASSY AN ESTABLISHMENT FOR
SENATOR RUBEN.
I LIKE THESE PEOPLE GETTING PUT
ON THE LIST AND THEY ARE LIKE
BRING IT ON, I DON’T CARE ABOUT
YOUR STUPID LIST.
THE REASON WHY THERE’S MORE
TRUMP VOTERS THIS TIME AROUND IS
BECAUSE OF THIS TYPE OF
BULLYING.
PEOPLE WHO I TALK TO HIM IF HE
WERE NOT POLITICAL OR PEOPLE WHO
CHANGED FROM BEING MORE LIBERAL
TO CONSERVATIVE TALK ABOUT THIS
EXACT ISSUE.
THEY GET BULLIED AND WHICH
HUNTED ITS NOT BEING ABLE TO BE
EMPLOYED BECAUSE THEY DISAGREE
WITH THE STATUS QUO MAINSTREAM
MEDIA NARRATIVE ABOUT HOW THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO THINK.
IN AMERICA WE ARE FREETHINKING.
THAT’S WHAT WE PRIDE OURSELVES
ON.
IT’S ANTI-AMERICAN TO MAKE LISTS
OF PEOPLE TO RUIN THEIR LIVES
JUST BECAUSE THEY WORK FOR
SOMEONE YOU DISAGREED WITH.
>> Greg: I’M NOT GOING TO
COMPARE THEM TO HITLER OR NAZIS
MADE BECAUSE I DON’T DO THAT.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS TREND.
IT’S WHY YOU HAVE SHY VOTERS.
THE AMOUNT OF SHY VOTERS IS ONLY
GOING TO GROW.
>> Dana: KATIE WAS SAYING, A
FRIEND OF MINE WORKED FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS WITH SUBURBAN
PEOPLE, A MIX OF MEN AND WOMEN.
THEY TALKED EVERY WEEK ABOUT
ISSUES AND WHEN CANCEL CULTURE
WAS BIG IN THE NEWS, THAT WAS
THE NUMBER ONE MOTIVATING FACTOR
FOR THEM TO NOT VOTE FOR
DEMOCRATS.
IT DIDN’T MEAN THAT THEY LOVED
VOTING FOR TRUMP BUT THEY
WEREN’T GOING TO SUPPORT THE
DEMOCRATS.
JON OSSOFF, THE DEMOCRAT IN
GEORGIA, HE SAID HE DID NOT WANT
TRUMP SUPPORTERS TO EVER BE ABLE
TO SHOW THEIR FACES AGAIN.
I MEAN, COME ON.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO HEAL WHEN
YOU’VE GOT LANGUAGE LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE
WAY BETTER LOOKING THAN BIDEN
SUPPORTERS.
IF ANYONE IS NOT GOING TO SHOW
THEIR FACE, IT SHOULD BE BUYING
SUPPORTERS.